what I do is I create music that
hopefully entertains people or inspire
his people makes people feel good makes
people fall in love again makes people
think that's what I do um I do it first
of all as a creative process trying to
write something special for people
trying to write something that is a
beautiful piece of artwork trying to
write something that feels good for me
to sing and and hopefully will feel good
for people to listen to and then I try
to translate that into a great
performance I try to put on a great
concert try to you know bring all these
influences I have together and make it
an entertaining spectacle for people to
see in here that's mainly what I do i do
a lot of other things too but those are
the main things that you
you